ransacked and wrecked after months of
russian occupation
we drove the empty roads north of harkev
checking reports russia has pulled out
completely
ukrainian soldiers in this dugout had
just had a narrow escape an attack
taking out half their position injuring
one of them two three hours ago there
was a russian drone here and after that
shelling came the russians are still
attacking
so they haven't given up yet in hakeem
is he scared to start sitting here
every person is caring about his life
the russians are in retreat but how far
back they've moved is far from clear
ukrainians say that they have
ukraine say they have pushed the
russians back to the border and won the
battle for harkeev there's clearly a lot
of artillery still flying around though
and we've been told that they don't
really know exactly where the russians
are
we went to a village to the east of
kharkiv to see what the russian retreat
has left behind
the russians came to mala rohan in march
but face fierce resistance with
civilians caught in between
alexander was stuck in the village as
the fight went on and lost a close
friend
my friend died near his home we used to
play football together he was a young
man
we went through a lot together
it's impossible to talk without emotions
i would like to but
i can't i'm sorry
we found hanadi in the rubble of his
home completely destroyed by russians
huahi says his own flesh and blood
i will tell you about one small paradox
i am russian by nationality i was born
in russia and moved here when i was four
years old and russia guys russia is evil
in the vegetable garden of one house
they were digging up the rich black
earth
when the russians attacked the village
they admit his husband michelo was
killed by a shell
she buried him alone in a shallow grave
now his body is evidence in ukraine's
war crimes investigations she says she
wishes she hadn't survived
it's very difficult i would like to have
died with him to stay with him there
as the russians pull back the land they
occupied is revealing the full extent of
the anguish they've left behind
dominic waghorn sky news
marla rohan